On the animation, control rig and sequences side, this is essentially how we can get things
moving inside of Unreal Engine.
So the Skeletal Mesh Editor that we were referring to before, all editors can be accessed from
these editor windows.
And so this is the mesh layout version of the Skeletal Mesh.
And you can see that we have settings pertaining to the mesh, such as the materials that the
Skeletal Mesh is using on the left-hand side there and the material slots.
You can set the level of detail, which is an LOD.
Morph targets can be used here and then can be accessed via the editor.
The animation blueprints are the event graph for the logic.
So you can, it's almost like a state machine type setup here, where if you want to transition
your character from a run to a walk animation, for example, you could do that through the
event graph in the animation blueprint and event graphs for animation.
You can control it and blend the different animations inside of here as well.
Control rig, as I said before, is how you can create tools and controls for animators
to animate directly inside of Unreal Engine.
So it is through a plugin, which is automatically on by default.
So you can access this inside of Unreal.
We build automated rig with familiar functionality and you can expose the controls for animators
to use.
It's a very powerful procedural animation tool as well.
And we can also write scripts to automate the workflow.
So we have Python support.
So if you want to use any Python tools, that kind of workflow is exposed to you inside
of Unreal Engine.
And Sequencer is Unreal Engine cinematic tool where it is essentially a nonlinear animation
system.
So we can animate assets inside of here.
We can use control rig assets inside of here to animate as well.
We've got editable tracks, which you can add keys and different data, such as animations
and audio files to.
You have sub sequences, which keep things nice and organized, controllable assets and
the cinematics tool, which you can add cinematic cameras and create different cut scenes, which
you can either then run in real time or you can render out as a pre-rendered video.
Other animation tools to consider here are the retargeting of IK retargeting.
So if you want to use a series of animations across multiple characters, you can do that
inside of Unreal Engine.
We also have face capture, which is the iOS app for FaceAR, which you can get data and
project that onto your mesh inside of Unreal Engine.
Live link, so any mocap systems you're using, you can create a live link between Unreal
Engine and interface that so you get the data directly into the engine.
And also there's the Alembic geometry cache.